normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is a clip from catchup katchup feed not
katchup as in it's in catchup with the
news and it says uh quote I have anxiety
I'm indigenous I'm n binary it's a video
of a woman who was uh presumably driving
drunk the wrong way down the road and
she gets pulled over and this is what I
I'm sorry jenz but y'all are going to
have to uh have some explaining to do
here
and so uh we're going to play we're
going to play this video for you right
now why are you driving in the wrong way
of traffic no I just got changed around
I just moved here like 2 months ago and
I just got changed around okay do you
understand what's going on though you're
going into oncoming traffic I know and I
just decided that it was better just to
turn around really quick okay but I'm
sorry I just have like really bad social
anxiety and stuff I I don't want to step
out whenever you're asking
for stuff okay well we're past that so
just go ahead and step out an indigenous
person oh just wait it gets it's good I
saw clips of
this sentence
there Perry look am I well I'm nonbinary
so okay what do you go byy Kai how can I
refer to you tonight Kai okay hey I'm
smelling alcohol this cop's trying so
hard great job three drinks need to run
you through some tests right now why
would you ever ad but I just want you
know that I also have very bad social
anxiety you and me both who
doesn't her face is I don't believe you
I'm the only one who got social anxiety
yeah I'm only I'm only I'm allowed to be
a victim yeah right focus on my finger
please I am you're just like trying to
intimidate me I don't know how I'm
trying to do that oh this is the test as
you know as an indigenous person and
breath with that one I'm sorry but it's
just for me to be on my toes I you can
you remember that I told you that I'm
nonbinary the hardest I'll right perfect
I need to know if you have any injuries
how I'll
remember do you have any injuries
physical injuries mental mental yeah
yeah just
says depression anxiety I get you
medical history now with your right foot
place it in front of your left in a heel
to toe touching manner with your arms by
your side just like this ma'am the cop
is being so nier he misgender right I'm
trying my hardest trying my hardest okay
it means a lot to me I'm trying my
hardest feel like a man so okay it's
kind of triggering right foot in front
of your left nope go back it feels like
it could be a par man thing just like
she saw I can't walk forward now because
you call
me have zero questions wait it get crazy
gets crazy here no but I just want to
tell you that I suffer from really bad
anxiety then don't drive right shouldn't
be driving with generational trauma and
oh my God dud stop how old is she she
acts like her ancestors were slaves
literally here we go it's
just I'm going to speak with you right
over here okay no yes ma'am go ahead and
place your hands behind your back just
admit that you were drunk don't make it
hard please make it hard listen no
you're you're going to get resist dude I
you're going to get resist I don't don't
resist okay don't listen to me don't
resist don't you're being a white man
and I followed all of
your whoa I did everything you said and
I'm getting in trouble you guys hold on
hold on are scaring me there's nothing
to be afraid what does it mean you're
being a white man I think we all know
there's nothing I can do about it I've
been a white man my whole life it's a
slur she's using it like a
slur you're being a white man being kind
to you no no like this is this an
important point he's arresting her yeah
she's getting in trouble she's claiming
that you are harming me you are being a
white man is an insult to someone
normally in her circles I bet that works
I bet when some guy says something like
no I'm I'm not going to give you the
last SCE of pizza she goes you're being
a white man he goes you're right I'm
sorry here's the pizza this cop is like
lady you're driving the wrong way down
the road into oncoming traffic I don't
care you're right sorry for electricity
she ad having three beers which is
probably less than she had too and she's
like reating what she just said like
five minutes ago too it's not a she's
saying all these things so she can be
like well it's it's actually that he was
being mean to me it wasn't that I was
drunk I she led with her excuses cuz she
know she's in the wrong you know the
advice that I was given was just don't
do the field sobriety test and uh don't
talk and and your worst case scenario is
they arrest you and give you the
breathalyzer back at the station and uh
I'm not a lawyer but I recommend
Consulting a lawyer more importantly
don't drink and drive and don't go the
wrong way down the road and uh well she
just moved here she doesn't know oh she
she can't read Street sides they were
different it's the generational trauma
that makes it so that she got her
license in which you have to take a a
written test to get your license but
then she forgot you can't drive the
wrong way down bring
her fast don't your driv ancestors the
babyon bees got to got to make a parody
of this one they could go I don't think
you could
par recent you know I got to be honest
you're you're you're actually it's
probably true I would like a followup I
want to know what happened when she got
to the police station I bet this police
officer went home to his wife and was
just he didn't even know guess what
happened
today that's amazing you're being I
might get brought up on hate crimes but
I I mean I would love it if she got
charged with uh like some kind of hate
crime charge you know I say that only
like half seriously no I think she
should because if the woke left wants
all these hate crime charges then if you
insult or attack or deride a person
based on their race then you should get
resisting and like invective or whatever
if she had looked at him and said you're
being a black man right now know right
it would have been so different it would
have been so different like can you
imagine especially considering his wife
that's it would have been complicated
then but like the fact that she can use
your your your being a white man as a
slur and we all kind of are like so
crazy except in another version of this
we would all be like that's a completely
inappropriate thing for her to say is
actually not okay because it's treating
one racial group in a way that we don't
treat others um so the the reason I
wanted to bring this up is we just did
that that we had that big survey showing
Jen's changes now I mean come on there
are a lot of sane and rational genzi and
we see it in the data they are pushing
away from this kind of insanity and
they're saying
enough I got to say like if I was a gen
Z guy and I was seeing this I'd be like
stop giving us a bad Bad Name man that's
how I feel I'm gen Z and I watch this
video and I'm like are you serious right
now I'm with the Boomers leave me alone
and this person only cares about they
themselves you know like they them I did
the best I could Kai only cares about
Kai right they Kai does not care that
Kai has been drinking and driving and
could hurt someone else Kai does not
care that Kai is going down Retreat Kai
has drinking and driving is a social
construct right Kai has excuses like
there's no tomorrow and ultimately
everyone should care about Kai even
though Kai has to care about no one else
that that's
ad to drinking that blows my mind you
know I got to be has generational trauma
and there Justified I'm willing to bet
single family a single parent household
single mother guaranteed I would say
guaranteed single mother household or
two mothers one of the two but most most
likely single mother what one thing that
always really offended me because this
happened a lot when I worked at Fusion
it Fusion was very leftist and woke and
that whole Trend started about the talk
and you had those commercials where it's
like you know uh black families have to
give their kids the talk and I was like
whoa what's that and then they show they
played these videos where it was like a
black father talking to his son and be
like when you get pulled over turn the
dome light on engine off keys on the
dash wall on the dash hands on the wheel
and I was like oh yeah my dad gave me
that talk too and they went no he didn't
this is something that and I was like
wait wait wait hold on Legit this is the
yo I think you're talking about rich
people or something because everyone I
knew in my neighborhood no matter what
their race was got the talk but there
was this woke liberal lib talking point
that only black families get the talk
and and for I'll clarify the talk is
when a father explains or mother
explains to their kids what to do when
you're pulled over by the police EV
every everyone I know of every different
race was told if you get pulled over
turn the engine off with the keys in the
dash turn the light on put your hands on
the wheel then when they ask for your
license and insurance it's on the dash
you grab it and you can all your hands
are in plane view the whole time well I
got the talk and I come from a family of
police officers so that should show got
the talk in driver's head teach you that
dri yeah don't hit the gas pedal when
you get pulled over don't reach for
something turn the music down because
you know they they're stopping you they
don't want to don't reach for a glove
box all these things that's why it's
like you get pulled over you put your
insurance on the dash you put your wall
on the dash you put the keys on the dash
they know you can't drive the car's not
going to move the lights on that can see
everything you grab your wallet right
there and you I just wait for them to
approach with my hands where they can
see them because like you put your hands
on the wheel so they can see your until
they ask you to do something then well
and if you're armed you let them know
that you're armed I mean at least in
most situations but it also can back
that's bad advice uh different states
have different laws on this and you got
to talk to your lawyer about that one
some states require and some states
don't and some states create serious
problems if you needlessly start saying
things like that so that's I can see
that yeah don't don't listen to that
talk to your lawyer about yeah cuz
there's it's what I wondered because if
you're driving with like a gun in your
glove box and you have to get that's
usually like I'll have a gun in the
glove box and then you usually my
wallet's in the glove box or something
so and then you have to reach in and you
say hey officer I want you to know
there's a firearm in the glove box but
my wallet or my registration is also
there you can reach in if you'd like or
I can reach now you're cons sending them
search your vehicle y depending on the
jurisdiction it can get crazy where if
you offer an officer to check the car
they can search the whole thing and Ki
you out yeah that's nuts to me yeah I
don't know if it's true though but uh
when I was a kid they said if if uh the
cop asks you to open the glove box so
they can see you've just given a full
consent for the car correct yeah and
it's usually like some
argument of when he opened it I thought
I saw something so now I had to
investigate and he said it was okay that
I searched it so you know here's the
important thing the reason why you never
talked to Cops sorry cops the reason why
you never talk to Cops is because uh
there's this great uh Supreme Court
Justice who went over all the basics of
it but there's really one simple thing
are you and the cop going to remember
things the exact same way oh all that
matters cop could be the best nicest guy
in the world and he swears that you said
that you were going to shoot him up when
you said I'm going to root root him up
for your baseball team who knows he he
could interpret what you said
incorrectly or mishear you or something
or you can say he says uh what do you
what you know what do what you doing out
here hey you're speeding and you say
just out having fun and he hears just
out with my gun and then he goes I'm
going to need to step out of the vehicle
sir then when you go to court and you
say he illegally searched my vehicle the
cop says the driver informed me that he
was armed I searched his vehicle found
Contraband or found uh you know a
possession of illegal substances and you
can say I never said that I said I was
just out having fun and who's you're
going to believe you if however you say
literally nothing then he can't say
anything he can lie and then lie but but
if it's a you know in the instance
you're dealing with a good cop who's not
going to lie he's going to be like he
wouldn't talk to me you should always
keep it bare minimum I mean just give
them what they absolutely need in that
moment uh I would say give them what
you're legally required to give them MH
and then uh you know typically I just be
respectful and say you know with all due
respect I'll wait let me know when I'm
when when you're finished thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net